et passons
quand tout le monde
me dit aux gars ligne
dans les pattes si l'été il fait beau il
fait chaud et c'est aussi le moment des
heures vagabonde avant concert du
bénabar à lencloître on va visiter le
musée des échecs à schaerbeek l'hérault
venez avec nous
bonjour bienvenue sur la terre des
seigneurs de clairvaux première pierre
de construction 14 170 xvème siècle
léonard de vinci à peu près 15 ans
d'ailleurs la tour construite par là la
famille chabot premier détenteur du
domaine de clairvaux il existait deux
seniors il clairvaux après une rixe
entre ces deux seigneurie la famille
chabot est descendu à trouver de l'eau
et a construit cette tour que vous
trouvez derrière moi qui ai le bâtiment
de plus anciens d'un ensemble d'édifices
15e 16e 17e et 18e siècle construit à
partir de 1790 construction gothique
construction édification renaissance
avec les modèles qui nous parvenaient
d'italie ensuite bon construction
française 18e comme on va la trouver
aversa donc modèle très tardive
vous trouverez donc au château clairvaux
également une collection de jeux
d'échecs réunis par le propriétaire qui
a racheté les lieux dans les années 60
ce monument historique étaient des
membres est dans un état de destruction
complète après avoir restauré l'ensemble
des édifices il a voulu donner un nouvel
aspect aux visites en rassemblant des
jeux d'échecs ce qui permet à toutes les
générations du plus petit au plus grand
de s'intéresser au jeu de courrèges de
joutes intellectuelles aussi bien que
une transmission des savoirs historique
sur la construction d'un monument voilà
ce qui vous attend dans un
écrin de verdure c'est un de douves à
tout autour c'est surtout l'eau
effectivement qui permet de faire vivre
un ensemble de maisonnées dès le xvème
siècle
[Musique]